[Music]
it was announced earlier this week that
that man right there if you're watching
on NBCSN Johnny Stowell is going to be
scowling through TV screens all August
long as the Raiders are the hard knocks
candidate nobody wanted it this year it
was obvious there were five teams that
could be forced to do it under the
league's formula for determining which
teams can be forced to do it honorably I
think some sort of a deal was struck big
cats something was done to get the
Raiders to say okay fine we'll go ahead
and do it they didn't want to do it Mark
Davis said in March we don't want to do
it not this year Jon Gruden made it
clear he didn't want to do it they're
doing it and they're the perfect team to
do it this year with all the stuff
that's going on but they have so much
stuff going on the last thing they need
is another distraction that comes in the
form of all those cameras all those
microphones chronicling everything that
happens at training camp as a fan I'm
very excited I wanted the Raiders the
Raiders are probably the most compelling
story of the team's you mentioned
Antonio Brown Mark Davis and Jon Gruden
getting the same haircut there's a lot
of things you can go with this more than
anything I think is the league saying if
you're gonna move a team because this
happened with the Rams if you're gonna
make all the owners vote for a new
stadium and and get up there and back
you well guess what you're the one who
has to carry it when it come to the one
that when the bill comes due and someone
has to do hard knocks cuz no one wants
to do it but this is what happens if you
want to move you see your team if you
want to get a new stadium you're gonna
have to do hard knocks if Mark Davis
wanted to reach truly legendary status
and if he wanted to show to all of us
that he is self aware one of the scenes
of the first episode of hard knocks
would be mark Davis goes to the barber
wouldn't it yes yes we've done that with
groom yeah Dean chairs right next to
each other correct or mark Davis goes to
PF Changs or just an inside view of
market conversion which by the way I
don't have scoops in my life but the
Mark Davis conversion man was one of my
scoops I actually had that back in the
day I was the one who broke the news
that he drove around in a white
conversion van or might be even just a
minivan with the license plate r8e are
and he just drives around in that all
the time and it's
hilarious site hilarious visual so it's
gonna be good and you have you know
obviously the internal Brown derrick
karr you have some Tom Cable who's
probably gonna fight someone there's all
kinds of storylines that we can go with
here the Raiders are fascinating mike
Mayock sitting with Jon Gruden in these
rooms I think more than anything though
Mike I think Jon Gruden is going to get
the court of public opinion back on his
side from this because he's good on
camera everyone knows that and he can
talk to people and I think this is
actually a bone as bad as it may be to
do hard knocks from a team perspective I
think this helps Jon Gruden personally
you didn't mention vantes Burfict to
Richie incognito those two guys on the
field at the same time in training camp
practice popping each other knocking out
the spider webs in late July is gonna be
something that you definitely want to
have the cameras rolling for and I think
big cat that Jon Gruden ultimately
didn't want to do hard knocks because he
knows that he will play to the cameras
that he will slide back into the role of
the guy who was in the booth at Monday
Night Football or the guy sitting in his
conference room doing the quarterback
camp and he may lose sight of why he's
there he's there to coach the team but
all of a sudden it becomes I'm the star
of the TV show and he's gonna play that
up and it may take some of his focus
away from what he needs to do I think
that's why he didn't want to do it and I
go back to the day he was introduced as
head coach of the Raiders that same day
Matt naggy was introduced as head coach
to the Bears and they did press
conferences the same day and nagi's was
horrible in comparison and Gruden's was
great and it was compelling and you
could see nine years of TV jump off the
screen but the bottom line is naggy
ended up being coach of the year and Jon
Gruden ended up with a four and 12 team
so there's a real disconnect between how
you play on camera and how you play when
it's time to show up for your games and
this is not gonna help the Raiders be
any better when it's time to play games
but don't you think Jon Gruden you know
showing just basic competency on camera
and being a dynamic speaker will help
this whole Jon Gruden is outdated and
Jon Gruden doesn't know the NFL anymore
I just think until September what until
September dummy but I think back to Hugh
Jackson in Hard Knocks last year
and that scene when he was trying to
convince his coaching staff that guys
need to be healthy for a team that has
it won one game in two years and that
scene where he basically said hey I'm
the boss it's my way or the highway I'm
not even being a miming this
collaborative effort here I remember
that scene so vividly and saying wow
this is worse than I thought
huge accident is worse than I thought
and actually just a really bad manager
of talent and boss because that's what a
coach is part of the job is just being
everyone's boss Jon Gruden will excel at
that and any little bit helps
when you come off a season like that
where you trade khalil Mack and win as
little games as does so I think I think
this is gonna help I really do and big
head I think that scene you've referred
to from the very first episode of last
year's hard knocks is the reason why
nobody wants to do it right there's no
benefit that comes out of years well on
hold on you can do hard knocks and not
be a terrible boss and manager of talent
those are won't have to be a terrible
boss or a terrible coach like Hugh
Jackson there is an alternate choice
like listening to yours veto
subordinates and I don't disagree with
that but you don't have to let it be in
the final cut that was the problem the
bird fryers Hugh Jackson can't like and
I'm not saying he's doing this but Hugh
Jackson can't be like man Hard Knocks
really got me you know who got you Hugh
Jackson got you no I don't disagree with
that but my point is this when you allow
that element into your building when
they're there when the producers are
saying oh this is a great scene trust me
we have to this is gonna make you look
real and this is the stuff fans want you
know I think the Raiders above all else
and I don't know this but I would have
wanted it if I was Mark Davis or Jon
Gruden or mike Mayock especially mike
Mayock who has no patience for any of
this crap I would want to be sure that
I've got the ability to watch this thing
the night before it airs and I've got a
blank check to say that goes that goes
that goes okay one last thing about this
don't you think Mark Davis and I don't
know where his head is at but in terms
of moving your franchise and selling
season tickets to Las Vegas this is a
good thing
Hard Knocks gets you familiar with every
guy on the roster there's always a guy
that people will look back
can remember that name you know he might
not be a superstar but when you get on
Hard Knocks you feel more connected to
the team and if they are trying to sell
this team to Las Vegas and a totally new
fan base I think this helps it gives
them you know a higher probably you know
higher look in the public eye I think
that all helps the Raiders I don't think
the Raiders need it because they're the
Raiders and I've heard the justification
in the past that teams have done this
like the Bengals or the Dolphins of the
Texans to establish a national presence
there's one way to establish a national
presence and that's winning football
games and the Raiders already the
Raiders to their credit the power of the
brand is they can stink for a generation
and they still have fans everywhere this
isn't going to help them look if they
thought this was going to help him
they'd have been at the front of the
line to do it they didn't want to do it
they view this as a burden and an
inconvenience and a distraction and
that's gonna make it even more
intriguing how much of that is gonna
bleed into what we see on those five
episodes that will come in early August
that so it makes it even more compelling
from my perspective because I know deep
down they don't want to do it mm-hmm
just give us Marc Davis getting a
haircut that's all we asked for i-i'll
tell I'll take that Nate just that for a
full hour
put Marc Davis in LeBron James barber
shop and then there's the show there's
hard not
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports